au chapitre de la contamination des sols
les bilan environnemental de certaines
industries et parfois peu reluisants
elle laisse en héritage des sols
contaminés dont on ne sait souvent que
faire heureusement des chercheurs
s'intéressent de plus en plus au
formidable pouvoir des plantes qui
pompent les contaminants et arrive à
ramener de la vie dans ces sols
[Musique]
on est dans l'arrondissement de pointe
aux trembles rivière des prairies de la
ville de montréal on est vraiment au
coeur de l'industrie pétrochimique dans
l'est de montréal ici
on est sur un site
typique d'une friche industrielle
donc territoires abandonnés par des
activités passées des industries
[Musique]
depuis quelques années ces parcelles de
terrains sont au coeur d'un projet de
recherche en décontamination
[Musique]
alors il ya de tout vraiment dans ses
soldats donc c'est une contamination
beaucoup en hydrocarbures pétroliers est
un petit peu en métaux aussi qu'ils
présentent il ya eu aussi des activités
de dépotoir à neige qui amène aussi une
charge importante de contamination
la technique habituelle de
décontamination et d'excaver le sol
retirez les sections contaminés et de
les enfouir ailleurs cette technique
al'avantage d'être rapide mais les
coûteuses et ne fait que déplacer le
problème
ici l'équipe étudie une pratique moins
coûteuse mais qui demande temps et
patience la phytoremédiation la
décontamination des sols par des
végétaux quand on arrive sur les sites
souvent le portrait qu'on a c'est ce
qu'on peut voir ici donc c'est un site
qui est souvent complètement contaminés
mais mais surtout recouvert d'un gravier
est recouvert d'un d'un substrat
quitterait contact et ça c'est notre
travail de chercheurs de trouver comment
on peut par des approches végétal aller
décontaminer ces sept là
ces sols sont très pauvres et surtout
rempli de contaminants organiques et
inorganiques
les contaminants inorganiques ce sont
les métaux le cuivre le plomb le zinc ou
le sélénium
les contaminants organiques
ce sont entre autres les résidus
d'hydrocarbures pétroliers
une décontamination par phytoremédiation
utilise ainsi deux stratégies
différentes
d'abord la phytoextraction
quand on veut enlever des métaux on a
besoin d'un plan qui va les capter et
qui vont absorber ces métaux qui vont
les transloquées grandir les amener dans
les parties aériennes
et il y à la phyto dégradation
[Musique]
tout ce qui est organique ce qui est
dans le sol la pétrochimie tout ce qui
résulte ça ça ça reste dans le sol ça
monte pas d'un plan alors là la
stratégie c'est de trouver une façon
d'avoir des plantes qui font beaucoup de
racines et qui vont aider la microflore
son voeu des microorganismes du sol a
dégradé ses molécules la grande question
quelle plante peut bien faire ce travail
sur ces parcelles on essaie depuis
quelques années diverses espèces de
peupliers et de soul on sait déjà que
ces arbres s'adapte très bien à
différents milieux complexe alors dans
un milieu ouvert par exemple après un
feu ou un milieu qui a été complètement
rasée pour une raison ou une autre les
premières plantes ligneuses aux arts
barbus qui vont s'établir c'est souvent
des peupliers des sols c'est souvent ces
espèces le bon que ce sont des espèces
tout à fait adapté à ce genre de milieu
là on est sur des sols très très pauvre
contaminés mais étonnamment malgré tout
la croissance elle est bonne alors la
leçon qui est là il commence une
troisième saison dont celle des cas 2
andres 2 en tiges sont qui mesurent déjà
deux mètres cinquante presque donc c'est
ça qu'on veut
mais comment ces végétaux parviennent
c'est la pousser dans un sol si pauvre
c'est vrai qu'au premier aspect ça fait
un petit peu désertique apocalyptique
limite
donc il a fallu casser des compacts et
tout ça avec la grosse machinerie des
grosses épines qui viennent vraiment
travailler en superficie le sol pour le
rendre beaucoup plus meuble
après une bonne préparation du terrain
l'équipe plantes des boutures dans un
nid de compost
juste en quatre jours il ya déjà des
bourgeons qui sortent et à partir du
moment où il ya de l'eau qui on leur a
donné de la matière organique en les
plantant aussi pour les aider ça va
extrêmement vite
en plantes également de longs morceaux à
l'horizontale voilà qui est étonnant
c'est une technologique et plus rapide à
mettre en place sur le site que à la
main à main donc on essaie de voir après
ok pour le même type de temps où le
différent type de plantation laquelle va
être la plus avantageuse aussi dans le
temps
quelques mois plus tard après une saison
entretient déjà le changement ici est
saisissant c'est un succès on est très
content le fait d'avoir de la végétation
qui pousse vite nous aident à créer cet
impact visuel savons que de remettre de
la vie dans un sol même aussi pauvre
avec un peu d'effort en apportant un peu
matière gagner comme du compost et on
arrive à remettre assez rapidement la
végétation
à l'automne l'équipe taï les arbres pour
favoriser une meilleure croissance la
biomasse ainsi récupéré par vers
l'incinération les contaminants dans les
cendres seront alors traités comme des
produits dangereux mais une partie de la
biomasse récoltés par un laboratoire
pour analyse
on va les traiter en valais broyé et de
la fin du compte extraire les
contaminants qui sont dans les tissus
végétaux dans les racines ou dans les
parties aériennes dont collective les
feuilles etc mais on va savoir quelle
est la concentration des contaminants
dans cette partie des tissus végétaux
on en analyse qu'une petite partie puis
après on extrapole sur l'ensemble du
site ça nous permet vraiment de donner
une valeur moyenne de l'état de la
contamination et d'extraction dire en
gros sur un hectare avec telle
technologie phytotechnologies on est
capable d'extraire temps 2 kg
de métal par hectare par exemple
on sait déjà que les peupliers et les
sols sont efficaces en phytoremédiation
mais il ya de nombreuses sous espèces et
autres plantes à évaluer trouver la
combinaison idéale de végétaux pour
décontaminer un site n'est donc pas une
mince tâche ce qu'on recherche c'est des
plans qui pose vite qu'ils font beaucoup
de biomasse et qui ont en plus la
capacité de concentrer et d'accumuler
des métaux ou des contaminants ça c'est
la meilleure des planques sauf qu'elle
existe pas
la recherche jusqu'ici s'est surtout
fait pour créer des cultivars qui pose b
qui sont résistants aux maladies aux
résistants à certains insectes etc mais
pas encore des saules adaptés aux
conditions de phytoremédiation
maintenant
on pourrait imaginer par exemple prendre
les caractéristiques des saules qui pose
vie qui font beaucoup de racines mais
les caractéristiques d'une autre plante
qui est une spécialiste pour l'enlever
du cadmium ou du plomb ce que le sol est
pas tout à fait capable de faire aussi
efficacement que d'autres espèces de
plantes alors oui on y pense à ça mais
là il ya des enjeux des tic d'une des
enjeux écologiques etc mais en reste
pour moi que quand on est dans un milieu
fortement entreprises et donc dans un
site industriel
contaminés on pourrait se doter de bons
outils biologique bien contrôlé et avoir
deux peut-être une belle solution pour
améliorer les choses pour le bien de la
planète
la phytoremédiation est encore à l'étape
expérimentale au canada on estime qu'il
faut environ de 10 à 15 ans pour
décontaminer ces parcelles mais au moins
il ya déjà un résultat bien évident le
retour de la verdure et cela change tout
quand on a mis notre végétation on amène
aussi de la vie on amène on remet de la
vie avec tout ce que ces plantes leur
amène parce qu elle purifie le sol elle
purifie aussi l'air c'est un des gros
capteurs de gaz carbonique donc ça
décontamine aussi l'air mais ça amène la
vie de la biodiversité
depuis qu'on a des armes ici on a
beaucoup plus de d'oiseau on a des
nicheurs qu'on va on repère dans nos
sols et on a ramené cette villa de façon
visible mais toute la vie qui ramenait
dans le sol ça donne un poumon vert au
secteur qui est qui manque de verdure on
ramène de la vie